[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais
j'ai jamais pensé
que je pouvais être aussi fier d'être
Québécois que ce soit
au soir du 15 novembre 1976 au centre
Paul Sauvé les partisans du Parti
Québécois sont déchaînés
le Parti québécois remporte 71 siège sur
110 alors très peu de personnes
s'attendaient un tel triomphe on raconte
que René Lévesque lui-même n'avait pas
prévu de discours de victoire à la pour
la soirée électorale de 1976 élégamment
le Premier ministre Robert Bourassa
battu dans sa circonscription conseil de
la victoire j'accepte évidemment le
Verdez que la population jamais il
n'aurait prévu une telle défaite en
convoquant une élection anticipée il
pensait pouvoir prendre l'adversaire par
surprise comme lors de sa victoire
éclatante de 1973 avec sa puissante
machine électorale
j'ai décrété la tenue d'élection
générale de 15 novembre prochain mais en
six ans de pouvoir l'étoile de Robert
Bourassa a bien Palli le taux de chômage
s'emballe l'inflation égale à peinte le
parti de libéral mené par Robert
Bourassa mais sur la table la loi 22
pour régler la situation linguistique du
Québec elle insatisfait à la fois les
anglophones et les francophones bref le
Parti libéral du Québec est en train de
creuser à ce moment-là sa propre tombe
on a été le premier gouvernement à faire
du français la langue officielle du
Québec et ça les séparatistes ne peuvent
pas l'accepter au moment où ça se
déchire entre la majorité de la minorité
à cause de leur donner bêtises avec la
loi 22 on avait dit dès le début les
tests sur des petits enfants ce serait
fondamentalement quelque chose d'odieux
ça marcherait pas
et puis il y a les grèves les coups de
son projet du siècle les barrages de
Labé James explosent pareil pour ceux du
Stade olympique inachevé pour les jeux
sur la question constitutionnelle il se
heurte à Pierre Trudeau qui lui témoigne
son plus profond méprises
président du Parti québécois est très
populaire mais il sait qu'il n'a pas
l'appui nécessaire dans la population
pour réaliser son rêve la souveraineté
association ça prend davantage pour
faire élire un gouvernement qui se
réclame de l'indépendance ça prend la
promesse que va faire un élévaire de se
faire élire sur la base d'un bon
gouvernement un gouvernement qui est
capable de gérer convenablement les
finances publiques et d'adopter des lois
qui seraient progressistes et c'est sur
la base donc de cette plateforme
électorale et la promesse d'un
référendum qui s'en suivrait que va se
faire élire le Parti québécois
face à face Monsieur Robert Bourassa
rené-l'évêque le débat à la radio de
Séka c'est montre que les deux hommes
ont l'un pour l'autre un profond respect
le référendum c'est une gigantesque
feront des lecteurs pékistes qu'on
trouveraient le résultat le ton des
publicités
[Musique]
monsieur René Lévesque un homme qui
s'est écouté qui sait s'entourer des
publicités du Parti québécois soulignent
l'importance de l'équipe au son d'une
chanson de Stéphane ven qui deviendra
rengaine
ça va bien on prédit la faillite du
Québec la banqueroute de l'État
québécois et au soir d'ailleurs de
l'élection la première chose qu'on va
faire René Lévesque c'est ici de
rassurer l'ensemble de la communauté
canadienne mais aussi les investisseurs
leur disant le Parti québécois n'est pas
votre ennemi eux
mais l'élément décisif dans l'élection
du Parti québécois semble avoir été ce
qu'on a appelé la crise des gens de
l'air pourquoi parce que on avait promis
au gouvernement fédéral donc de Pierre
Eliott Trudeau de faire en sorte que le
Canada serait un pays bilingue de
l'océan à l'autre et là on s'aperçoit
que les francophones qui travaillent sur
les lignes aériennes c'est francophone
là ne peuvent même pas s'adresser entre
eux en français Radio-Canada à 8h40
prévoit que le prochain gouvernement du
Québec sera formé par le Parti québécois
et que ce gouvernement sera majoritaire
monsieur l'évêque en premier lieu
euh rassurer les gens
qui nous séparent pas la priorité c'est
de donner au Québec le meilleur
gouvernement qui soit exactement
d'ailleurs le premier mandat du Parti
québécois est un mandat dans son on se
rappelle avec souvent avec admiration
René évêque était particulièrement
satisfait et heureux d'avoir fait
adopter la loi sur le financement des
partis pour assainir on pourrait dire le
processus démocratique au Québec il y a
c'est incontournable la loi 101 qui
permet de vraiment d'afficher un visage
français au Québec il y a la Loi sur la
protection du consommateur il y a la
création du premier ministère de
l'Environnement
ce qu'on retiendra le plus de cette
soirée historique c'est ce cri du cœur
de René l'évêque
[Musique]
fierté cette idée que le Québec pouvait
s'affirmer sur la scène du monde qui est
capable de prendre en main son devenir
collectif je suis
que j'ai à peu près politiquement la
plus belle et peut-être la plus grande
soirée de l'histoire du Québec
[Applaudissements]